I'm headed home
I said dinner Michelle Vargas in
Brooklyn that's great but I got a
sometime
some sort of allergic reaction to
something in dinner let's start breaking
out in hives doesn't have to go home
just cause me and talk like this oh my
god what looks like a black cat just
crossed my back no look at home put a
bunch in to have some cuz gin helps with
hives so I hear from doctors who are
also bartenders um in some nice girl
named Jesse stopped us outside to say
hey she watches us on YouTube that's
cool it's so thick and sweaty here not
that it is sweaty I'm just sweaty Wow
so that's it that's all I want to tell
you my nose itches
well because there's a big old hive on
it anyway this is a car in passing this
is fun for them just see me talking to
myself that's cool simple fun times no
there's a there's a couple of classic
middle-aged women I'm gonna pass all the
weight they're saying goodbyes are just
one I guess I'm gonna pretend I'm
watching
okay
anyway how are you what's your sweat
range on scale of presentable not
presentable yeah cool for you all right
how many go
we call my mom yeah okay wait